nous les avions suivi il y a un an suite
à l'annoncé du premier confinement la
société les plaisirs fruité spécialisée
dans la livraison de fruits aux
entreprises a dû se réinventer
un an après qu'est devenue cette société
qui livré près de 1000 entreprises
chaque semaine avant le confinement ou
toutes les semaines on venait livrer des
compositions de fruits dans les bureaux
pour les pauses et ses destinations des
collaborateurs et lors du confinement
donc beaucoup de sociétés voire
intégralement toutes les sociétés ont
fermé on fait du télétravail et notre
service du coup a été mis en suspens par
la majorité de nos clients
la société est passée de 100 % de
chiffre d'affaires à 0 % en une semaine
face à la situation sanitaire les
plaisirs fruité s'est rapidement adapté
une boutique a ouvert à versailles et
une offre aux particuliers a été créée
pour proposer la livraison de fruits et
légumes à domicile on avait la flotte de
véhicules on avait le personnel
également qu'ils étaient qualifiés pour
donc on a mis en place en l'espace de
deux jours un site internet qui permet
aux particuliers
encore aujourd'hui de commander des
fruits et des légumes de saison et se
les faire livrer à domicile ou en
retrait
soit l'entrepôt trappe soit leur
boutique de versailles si l'activité
s'est poursuivie pendant l'année une
baisse du chiffre d'affaires et de
fréquentation du site a été observée en
dehors des confinement c'est vrai que
les confinements sont quand même assez
propice au commerce en ligne notamment à
la livraison à domicile parce que les
gens sont entre guillemets forcé de
rester chez eux
né en croissance on va dire constante
mais beaucoup moins importante que lors
des conflits
aujourd'hui certaines entreprises ont
repris leurs activités en présentiel et
les particuliers continue de commander
des fruits et des légumes
la vente aux entreprises représentent
70% du chiffre d'affaires 30 % pour les
particuliers